behalf of the Institute of International
Studies and the program on globalization
and religion I'm pleased to welcome you
today our guest is Loretta napoleoni
who is the author most recently of rogue
economics she's written extensively on
the financing of terrorism as an
economist and as a journalist for
several European papers so we're pleased
to welcome here to Berkeley today thank
you yes thank you very much for inviting
me to the series of lecture and thank
you to all of you for being here
so today I will talk about my new book
rogue economics capitalist new reality
and before I go into the details of the
book let me tell you how I got the idea
to write this book it actually happened
two years ago when I was in the States
promoting another book and a friend said
oh you must absolutely read this new
book Freakonomics and I thought sure so
I read the first chapter and all of a
sudden I thought interesting this is
just one tiny little aspect of what is
happening all over the world had
globalized level and and that made me
think that I'll do I do enjoy the
advantages of globalization I also had
always in the back of my mind a sort of
an easiness about that I was wondering
what is wrong with globalization and I
couldn't really pinpoint what was the
cause of this uneasiness and I think
this was very much a general phenomenon
and I understood that the reason why the
book was so successful is because he was
giving a answer to very uncomfortable
questions that people were asking
themselves inside the so-called global
village
but the idea to write a book actually is
linked to something else my youngest son
forced me literally forced me to watch
The Matrix I never wanted to watch the
film
because I thought oh this is one of
those teenager kind of film special
effects violent but in the end he said
mommy you got to watch it and for me was
really relation because all of a sudden
I understood why I was so uncomfortable
and the reason why I was so
uncomfortable
within this globalized economy is the
fact that all of us consumers but also
voters we run the risk to become numbers
on that screen the screen number the
scroll and this is when I decided that I
was going to research the dark side
let's say a Western capitalism and my
idea was there what was going wrong was
a unique phenomenon therefore there was
going to be a solution and the solution
was going to be linked to the reasons
why this globalization and not gone as
it should have gone and this was my
assumption and I started my research and
the other thing I did was not to limit
my research to the field of economics
but we take into consideration all
aspect of modern life because they're
all interlinked so I looked at politics
I looked at culture I looked at music I
even convinced one of my children to
make me understand why rap music is so
successful and that was I should quite
quite an experience them so in the end I
came out with the opposite conclusion
that in reality what is happening today
is not unique it is actually part of the
history of mankind we have seen rogue
economics happening in the past during
the Industrial Revolution during the
rush to the Californian gold after the
fall of the Roman Empire
a time so great fundamental import
and transformation the economy moves
much much faster than politics and
politics can't keep pace with it so in
this process we see the birth of gray
areas gray areas where there is not
legislation where there is not
regulation
inside this gray areas created by the
big economic transformation we see the
burst of what I describe as rogue
entrepreneurs individuals they basically
reap the benefits of this transformation
and also they take advantage of the
absence of any type of legislation so
rogue economics is very much a sort of
umbrella under which we do find the
criminal economy in the legal economy
because these are phenomenal they also
grow within rogue economics but also and
especially we do find this grey areas so
the final message really amortisseur she
was fairly positive because if history
can teach us something can teach us that
in the long run politics always regain
control of rogue economics and through
this process of rogue economics we
actually have great leap forward in
progress as it was the case of the
Industrial Revolution all the comforts
of modern life today they are one way or
another linked to Industrial Revolution
which was based upon the exploitation of
the weak and the poor at that time so
rogue economics will eventually and also
in this process the problem is what is
going to happen next and what is going
to happen next is basically reshaping of
the world not necessarily at our
advantage the advantages of the West but
for sure advantages of the East so we
see a movement a sort of shifting of the
center of the epicenter of the economic
but also the political life going away
from the west towards days so that's
basically the final message now
just to give you a very brief idea of
the most important components of rogue
economics we can isolate three I mean
you're the first one is the information
of these gray areas and the birth of
rogue entrepreneurs now the interaction
of the rogue entrepreneurs creates
newsreel interdependences and in that
economics did point out a few of them
taking place in the United States the
second aspect is the transition of the
nation state into a market state and the
third one is what I describe as the
market matrix this is a web of
commercial political and economic
engines and we live inside of it without
being conscious of living inside of it
now just to describe the birth of gray
areas and also our rogue entrepreneurs
can blossom inside these areas let's
look at the situation of the transition
of the former Soviet Union from a
centrally planned economy to a market
economy now at the time of the fall of
the Berlin Wall one of the biggest
problem was how can we monetize an
economy whereby money
had no meaning really inside the Soviet
Union we had to type occurrences there
was the non-convertible ruble and the
convertible ruble 70% of exchanges so
from normal trade to international trade
between the members of the Soviet bloc
took place with non-convertible rubles
which basically were pieces of paper the
remaining 30% was based upon convertible
ruble so those were money that could be
used in the black market primarily now
the black market was fundamental in an
economy
it was plagued by costs and shortages so
the government had encouraged the
maintenance and even the growth of the
black market so the real issue was how
can we convert these pieces of paper
into real money
now the central bank did not have enough
foreign currencies in order to convert
the non-convertible rubles it did not
even have enough convertible rubles
printing money was out of the question
because you would have inflated the
economy so they they needed to find a
mechanism through which this money could
eventually become convertible currencies
and because there was no Treasury in the
Soviet Union the decision was to give
the right to convert the currencies to
the communist youth club of the
universities now the majority of the
future oligarchs were president of these
youth clubs and I'll tell you the story
briefly of Khodorkovsky who eventually
became the owner of Yukos one of the
largest energy Holding of Russia now
kulakowski was the president of the
communist youth club of Moscow he was
given the right to organize scientific
meetings and scientific events the most
popular scientific events that were
organized were pop concerts and beauty
contests
they were extremely popular in Russia
so the mechanism this is just one of the
many many schemes thousand and thousand
that Khodorkovsky and the future
oligarchs were running simultaneously so
this is just one so it would organize a
beauty contest in Moscow people would
participate by paying in non-convertible
rubles it would then take these
non-convertible rubles and exchange them
for foreign exchange with timber
exporters from Russia it would take the
foreign exchange and buy computers in
the West and import them into Russia and
then start this mechanism all over again
because you would sell the computer for
non-convertible rubles and then it would
do exactly the same thing in Iran
thousand of these schemes now what is
interesting in this story
not only the formation of these gray
areas whereby the government delegates a
task which should be a governmental task
to single individuals but also the
creation of this surreal
interdependences and one of these is the
interdependencies between the
exploitation of the russian mafia of
women which were turned into prostitute
and sex slaves from the former Soviet
bloc in this process of monitoring Inga
the Russian economy the place where the
majority of women were lured into
prostitution or sex slavery in the West
was actually at the pop concerts a
beauty contest organized by the
oligarchs the future oligarchs this was
the ideal situation for the Mafia in
order to transform women into
merchandise now the reason why this
happened is because the Soviet economy
after the for a Berlin Wall basically
collapse and unemployment in certain
sector predominantly in the sectors
where women were employed skyrocketed so
we see female unemployment going from
virtually zero before 1989 to 70 to 80%
in the early 1990s
these women were desperate and you're
the only alternative was basically to
sell their body some so that's just one
I think interesting example of how rogue
economics can create new wealth can also
to a certain stand create new
interdependencies with not we're not
necessarily positive but for the
countries where this is taking place and
that brings me to the importance of
globalization in the rise of rogue
economics now globalization really
kick-started with the fall of the Berlin
Wall
I'll do we know through the 1980s we had
a strong tendency for Western capitalism
atubu belies
the area where this could take place was
very limited it was limited basically to
the free world it's only when the wall
came down the really global carbon atoms
could expand worldwide so the planet
became you know it's ideal environment
and this coincided the fall of the
Berlin Wall coincided with the spreading
of democracy now the number of
democratic countries goes from 63 before
the fall of the world 218 in the early
1990s and here we find another really
surreal correlation as democracies
spread so did slavery and the other day
the story I told you about you know the
sex slaves are coming from the former
Soviet bloc it's only the tip of the
iceberg we do find a very strong
correlation to the extent that the
statistic produced by the ILO which is
the International Labour Organization
show that slavery at the end of the
1990s reached a level of 27 million
people now when I talk about slavery I
do not talk about slave labor I talk
about people who are deprived of their
freedom who are owned by other
individuals and who are traded them as
merchandises now all of this took place
under the watch I would say of a state
which was progressively changing so from
the nation-state we are seeing a new
form of states which has been described
by philip orbit in his book the shield
of Achilles the market state now the the
nation state is a state where the
individual renounces certain kind of
liberties in order to be protected by
the state I mean so there is a sort of
social contract at the base of this
relationship
the social contract has to be respected
now so this social contract has
progressively changed since
globalization has taken place and we see
the birth of the market state the market
state is the states they create the eye
Geel condition for the individual or the
corporation in order to become rich this
is a state that wants to deregulate the
regularization of the economy he wants
to basically bring down any form of
barriers any form of economic and
financial barriers and indeed this is
what has happened since the fall of the
Berlin Wall we see for example that
there's been a massive influx of labor
coming from the east to the west to the
extent that the labor supply actually
doubled so that brought the the costs of
labour down because salary started to
decline at the same time the cost of
capital also started to decline because
we saw the beginning of a deflationary
policy a pursuit initially in the United
States and then in the rest of the
Western world now all of this of course
creates higher return on capital which
means if it create new wealth and we do
see the GDP figures of most of the
Western countries rising you know from
the beginning of the 1990s up to - until
the beginning of the year 2000 now what
is interesting is how this new world has
been redistributed or better how this
new wealth has not been redistributed
because during the same period we see a
rising trend in income inequality to the
extent that today the medium income of
the United States and we're talking
about the income which is sandwiched
between the rich and the poor is in real
terms so net of inflation lower than it
was in the early 1970s now the reason
why we see this income inequality is
predominantly because the state has
pursued policies which mean to a certain
extent at the advantage of the very rich
but also of people they want it to be
entered
Arielle and we're talking for example
about Wall Street and what has been I
financed through the 90s and part of
their 2000 and I think it's interesting
to visualize this income inequality and
this has been done by a dutch
statistician who has produced the income
parade so imagine the population of the
United States for example marching
according to their height so the
Shorter's one before and then the
tallest one at the end and the height
correspond to their income so you see
the progression started to march and the
very short people people that are below
the poverty line March for a very long
time and then we get people they are
very poor than March for another long
time then we get the middle class and
the middle class marches for hours an
hour then suddenly at the end of the
middle class when we are people that
maybe are six feet tall all of a sudden
we see people getting very very tall so
they are like you 300 meters four
hundred meters three kilometers and this
gives the idea of the sudden jump of
wealth and this is exactly the situation
that we have today and one of the reason
it is the fact that they the market
state has not redistribute the world
created by the process of globalization
because what the market states wants it
is to create the ideal condition for the
individual not for the society to
benefit and to become rich by the sudden
transformation which we're living a
globalization and this is also at the
root of what is happening today with
with the crisis of the supremum
this is the consequences of the creation
of a gray area inside finance whereby a
growing debt has been transformed thanks
to derivatives which are the special
effect
i financed into a growing asset and this
asset has been sold time and time again
all over the world and he has been sold
time and time again based upon the two
indicator one was interest rate falling
because of deflationary policy of the
Federal Reserve and number two by
increase in price of property produced
by the cheap and easy credit so people
were offered ridiculously advantageous
condition to borrow money in order to
buy properties condition that they could
not respect because of course they
should never been offered those
mortgages and these push the prices up
them so this is a gigantic bubble which
has began bursting in the present days
and this has happened while the state
was ignoring an area I finance where it
a major transformation was taking place
and I just give you one indicator to
show you that what is happening today
was perfectly predictable in 2006 the
rate of growth of personal bankruptcy in
the United States was higher than the
rate of growth of the GDP now that's a
fundamental indicator that things are
going majorly majorly wrong and yet
nothing has been done in order to
reverse the situation until the crisis
as karma so at the same time I would say
and this is the last aspect of rogue
economics we the consumers we also their
individuals who need mortgages in order
to buy our home we didn't know that all
of this was happening I mean now that we
are in a crisis we know a lot but a year
ago two years ago nobody really knew
exactly what was happening with this su
primer mortgage and the reason is
because we do live inside this market
matrix which is this web
of illusions we don't know exactly what
is happening outside this web and the
reality we perceived it is not really
what is happening and this is at any
possible level including the everyday
shopping now we don't know that a lot of
products that we consume are actually
produced by slaves and I'll give you an
example Coco the largest producer of
cocoa in the world is the Ivory Coast I
mean the Ivory Coast is a country where
there is a lot of slavery I mean
children the trek from Mali to the Ivory
Coast to work in the plantation of cocoa
are enslaved by the owners that kept
inside these places and you transform
into slaves and we don't know that the
fish wheat 70% of the fish we consume is
what is defined as black fish inside a
fish above the quota all fish by the
fish pirates or is fish in the
territorial water of other countries we
don't know any of those things so to
conclude I I've wrote this book to
understand exactly what was happening
and as I said before the the final
message is actually very good and I'll
tell you in a second why but I also
wrote this book in order to give the
possibility to everybody else to share
my research so to get out of this matrix
of illusion to become conscious of what
is really happening and this is I think
it's a great step forward this is not
gonna solve the problem rogue economics
for sure but but it's going to give us
the possibility to reflect upon what is
really happening and perhaps is going to
give us some ideas about how to go
forward they and finally the the
positive aspect of all of this is the
fact that eventually rogue economics
will disappear but we will have a new
system and this new system will be
assistant we're the developing countries
will have a much more important role
economically speaking but also
politically speaking that they have
today I mean China being perhaps you
know the most important but also the
Middle East and also Africa and I'll
just leave you with two interesting
thoughts about the positive side the
rogue economics now for the first time
because of the great increase in prices
of corn which has taken place recently
we're talking about an increase of
seventy five percent in the last 12
months Africa will have the possibility
to trade with the West without being
blocked by the tariff which has been in
position in our countries in order to
block this kind of trade to protect our
farmers and this is happening because
our farmers now you do not produce
enough corner so the price has gone up
and part is due to the fact of 40
percent of corn production Li Jie has
been diverted to biofuels but part is
also due to the fact that demand in the
world is rising up so here we are in a
situation that we are in a crisis
because you know the increase in corner
is clearly in a crisis for the West it's
a crisis for the world but at the same
time it is a crisis that is offering new
opportunity to a continent they until
today and never add this kind of
opportunities and the other thought is
Islamic finance now Islamic finance is
the sector of international finance has
grown the fastest in the last decade
it's not only because there is 1.3
billion a Muslim in the world but also
because it is an alternative to Western
finance now Islamic finance is the only
sector of international finance does not
subscribe the subprime mortgages so if
there is a domino effect which is what
the Fed fears so if we have one
Bank collapsing either in the US or in
Europe and then you know many others
link to it will follow suit there will
always be a sector International Finance
which is Islamic finance which will
withstand the crisis that we will be
totally shielded by the crisis that
means that we're not going towards
another 1929 we're going towards another
major crisis but it's not going to be a
global crisis so these are just two
aspects of our rogue economics it is
reshaping our world at our own
disadvantage for sure but is creating
new opportunity and uses them and
eventually this system will bring
politics back in control of economics
thank you we'll continue now in
questions and let me ask the first
question
why I'm not sure I understand why you
chose the term rogue economics and by
that I mean why rogue and why does what
you're saying in what way is the the
system held together I'm not sure I
understand how it all hangs together as
we would say in international politics
well the decision of the tiger lecture
was not very easy I must say because how
do you describe an economy that it's
clearly breaking laws but at the same
time is not breaking laws when the laws
are not there and should be there so you
can't really talk about criminal economy
you can't talk about illegal economy for
sure you can't talk about ethical the
gone away because it's two concepts do
not go together so the idea of rogue was
really to describe this gray areas the
the world is can be positively can
negative meaning rogue can also mean
people who are particularly smart and
understand how the economy is changing
and therefore they anticipate the change
and they take advantages of it and they
can do it also without causing damage to
the society but the majority of the
cases says in the case of course of the
oligarchs you know the consequences were
near tremendous and the reason why this
takes place is because the state is
retreating from the position of control
of the economy so that's how we all
hangs together basically we so this
retreat taking place from the 1980s from
Reaganomics from you know mrs. Thatcher
privatization I mean the idea that the
market works better than the state
intervention and twist certain extent
one could say yes of course the market
works better because the market will
always find its own equilibrium in the
case of the sue Prime for example the
market could find the equilibrium in a
very short time let the way to do it
would be to let banks like burns kabila
go bust not intervene but if you do that
then the consequences of this adjustment
will be disastrous and I think this is
the real lesson of rogue economics is
that when the cycle is positive of
course
rogue economic can work marvels unknowns
state intervention is fantastic because
you can create immense wealth as we have
seen it in the 1993 okay just one second
question I'll open it to the floor and
that is but the con the notion that
capitalism is creative destruction is
not new and the the antagonism between
international capitalism and the state
is not new I mean that that's
long-standing right oh yeah no no
absolutely I mean your cabin is as
creative disaster before but this is
exactly the
what I said about 1929 Road economics I
mean there was wrong economics also in
1929 and he did create a great
transformation if you think about
because you know then we had the state
intervention where the New Deal so we
had a new economic system which was
produced so I think what I'm trying to
explain to a certain said it's the fact
that during these crashes and and during
this disaster capitalism this state
either doesn't intervene because it
doesn't want to intervene or the state
cannot intervene because you can't
predict what is happening ok let's open
the floor to questions do you want
people to come to this or you just say
yeah ok yeah please yes today you really
see if anything a derogation towards
tribal event you see a fragmentation of
systems in the past this appliable ism
was kept under control certainly in the
post-world War two ERA in the developing
world by socialist economic principles
and political structures that kept
tribalism surprise now we see that
eroding and if you look at Africa with
this resource they should be able to
live again there is no lack of examples
of resource rich African countries which
have gone don't work so it's not the
fact that they will get more income fall
from corn that is going to solve the
problem a problem in Africa is tribal
the growth of tribal identity and
corrupt
which is uncontrolled the solution the
other than resources so yeah man this is
the conclusion of the book actually
unfortunately with short time it's very
hard to cover such a big topic now I do
talk extensively about tribalism in fact
there is a chapter which is called
economic tribalism Islamic finance is a
form of economic tribalism because of
course is based upon the partnership of
the Sharia but tribalism is even more
important because in the disintegration
of the left and right as you clearly
said now we have seen a sort of increase
in tribalism at any level
I mean rap music is a form of tribalism
also very much so so we see it in the
culture we also see it in politics and
we see it in economics with Islamic
finance the reason why we see this birth
October is it is as pop word said it is
a sort of retrenching from globalization
is fear basically the individual is
afraid but in the video it's also afraid
because he feels that the state is not
there anymore so you know we are in a
transition from this nation-state to the
market side therefore your trenches into
tribalism now how all of this is going
to create this new system it is through
the
between Islamic finance now Islamic
finance is a financial and economic
tribalism but it is extremely
sophisticated it is actually the sector
of more than finance that is mostly
sophisticated because it's very flexible
and the reason why it's flexible is
because every single product that is
produced has to be approved by a
committee the Sharia committee and in
the committee there are economists but
also there are religious experts and in
economics so potentially you can produce
any kind of product you can finance
anything from you know microcredit to
the construction of been a big industry
providing that you comply with the
Sharia so no interest rate no investment
in certain industries and the concept of
partnership now with this structure
which is extremely sophisticated could
merger with the economic structure of
China so we have a country which is
politically still the communist country
but which is applying the principle of
capitalism a country also which is
ideally shaped for globalization now the
merge of these two systems is what is
going to be the base for the next system
and the reason why these two
system will merge is that most likely
not only because of the current crisis
of Western finance but also of the ties
they have been built in the last decade
in areas of the developing world that
goes from the Middle East to Africa this
is where we see a lot of Islamic bank
funding Chinese initiative in order to
produce products and resources
especially which are needed by the
growing industry
China so to a certain extent Islamic
finance doesn't need so much to
industrialize if he merges with the
country that is industrializing the most
yes here mentioned in neither South
America nor India in South America is
talking about moving toward a common
market and the more European type of
structure moving itself from North
American influence how do you see South
America and India playing out in this
well I I think India for sure is going
to play a big role because it is one of
the emerging markets I'm not sure about
South America to be honest so I think
South America still as its economy very
much linked to the Western economy the
cycle the business cycle is very much
the same there are countries that are
trying to break away I think of all the
South American countries they can see
this they will do very well in this is
doing very well at the moment is Chile
in fact we have a sovereign fund created
in Chile because of booming exports but
it is a very isolated phenomenon when
you can't say the same thing of the rest
of sodomy you can't say the same thing
of Brazil which is also countries coming
out as an emerging market and yet we do
not have that type of redistribution of
wealth that can trickle down this new
world creation so I think it will lag
behind but India for sure yes another
question yes I think Africa is a very
interesting continent and in relation to
what we were talking before actually
one of the country that s grow the moss
is Botswana Botswana is one of the
countries that received the last yes is
very small but it's also one of the
country received that last financial aid
because we know the financial aid has
been disastrous I mean he ended up
sustaining this corrupted government so
the real problem of of Africa it is the
corruption but I do think that the the
Chinese kind of penetration of Africa
it's very different from the colonial
penetration of Africa which we have
pursued it's a completely different
model it doesn't mean the Chinese they
want Africa to develop because they're
good and we are bad but it's just a
different model and and the the
continent could benefit more from that
model then it did of course from the the
colonial classical model I'm not sure I
understand this future that you're
envisioning because at one level the
Chinese relations with the Muslim world
are really state to state relations
where it is in their interest to to get
out resources to use a capital that
might be coming from Islamic States but
I don't I don't I have a problem with
what you're saying because on the one
hand you're making a radical critique of
the present system by looking at pockets
of despair and obviously much is
unraveling but I don't see any formula
by which one will transition to the
future other than building a case that
seems to be overblown about what the new
order will look like just based on
relations that are occurring now say
between China you know and Saudi Arabia
are China and the Sudan well I mean none
of us has the crystal ball
very different even if you know working
and financed I can find out sometimes
they do well this is clearly a
projection I mean this is not we can't
prove it but this is the direction where
things are going now anything can happen
meaning we can have a leader a new
leader in in China or can reverse this
process this could happen I do not think
it will happen because this is an
irreversible process but it is true that
if you look at the economic and
financial situation the geopolitical
position of these countries the match is
perfect I mean the Chinese do not have a
financial sector that is sufficiently
sophisticated to sustain the
industrialization at the pace that
industrialization is taking place and
the Islamic finance is an extremely
sophisticated financial sector but does
not ever the industrial sector which is
needed in order to keep this growing so
the match is perfect and it is true that
there are tension inside China in
relationship to the various terrorist
groups the Islamic terrorist groups
which are in the evil region but that
has nothing to do with the relationship
which was being created with Iran with
Saudi Arabia with the United Arab
Emirates and these are very solid
cooperation agreements straight to state
state to state mm-hmm now in in an
economy where you ever I'm talking about
China where you have a communist
political umbrella the state state
relationship are a clear indication that
any kind of economic ties creative with
this
yes are accepted by the government so I
think that's a direction and I think it
is a very very strong direction but the
the Chinese economy and the Chinese
order right now although successful is
also very fragile wouldn't you admit
that I mean it it could unravel in the
same way that capitalism seems to be you
know unraveling today yes I think it's
it's very fragile but so are we yeah and
this is a point but this is acceptable
raga economics is all about I mean the
fragility of the system from any point
of view you look at it it's because
politics is not in control of the system
and that's exactly the same situation
that we had during the Industrial
Revolution there was a extreme fragility
before the Industrial Revolution after
the industry volution we add a much more
stable situation because politics I do
think that it is fundamental that any
economic system is supervised by a
political system without that we have
anarchy so so which political leaders
are likely to have the vision to to move
to the future because you you just
identified the problem and so then the
question becomes if you look at China
that the problem there is the the party
is unwilling to give up you know
political control so one has to then
following what you just said envision a
future and way in which they will work
toward achieving the alliance that
you're talking about yes what I think is
that at the end of this process there
will be a new social contractor and and
this is basically the end of the book
and in this new social contract there
will be a new negotiation which is
of course being we will take place not
here I said it in the past actually in
your Berkeley nothing the West but it
will take place in these now how are we
going to get there for sure the new
social contract will be based upon
demands from the population in order to
have better conditions so now it's not
going to be another nation state for
sure but it's going to be something
different where the individuals will
want to have certain kind of protection
but also certain kind of opportunities
guaranteed by the state and they will
negotiate that themselves now to get
there we will have to have a government
which is sufficiently open-minded to
understand that the negotiation is the
best way forward but I don't think it's
going to happen now and I tell you why
it's not gonna happen now because in
China you still have vast vast amount of
the population which is still on the
breadline so it is almost like we see
what is happening on the cost and then
you know that there are rows and rows
and rows of individuals who are waiting
for their turn in order to reap the
benefits of globalization
so wealth distribution will take a long
time and until we reach the last layer I
don't think there is going to be a
renegotiation and I think until we reach
the last layer the government will be in
a strong position to continue to
exercise a sort of an auto Italian kind
of politics because the force because
the strength of the people will not be
strong enough now how long is it going
to take it could take it depends on the
speed of the Chinese capitalism I think
probably it will take one maybe you know
two decades but I may be wrong
yeah let me see yes right here
couple of quick questions it's just the
first two are just very sort of quick
ones and you know most of what I heard
you talking about is basically a
critique of neoliberalism and
disconnected from that but I mean
there's there's you know global social
movement for the last 15 years have been
talking about all this and there's a
vast academic literature so you know why
is this you know why is what you're
saying different than what people have
been saying on this I didn't say that
yeah I mean did I say that what's coming
out of this that's adding to that what I
don't know do you wanna quote some
people that said this kind of thing
before me in the specifics or a video
there is a movement out there of course
there is a plenty of literature against
neoliberalism but I just did my analysis
with from my point of view so I don't
send the question just in terms of in
terms of Muslim economies Islamic Muslim
oh okay well it said in the title Muslim
economies we should idle the advertised
however they like so sorry about that
I'm sorry
so in terms of Islamic finance and and
and thinking of
original economy in the Islamic world it
seems like you're creating an equal sign
there that is a little bit shady because
Islamic finance is one thing it's it's
an industry of particular way of doing
finance there's some banks right from
our the Islamic countries that do is on
the finest or some that don't now if
you're making an argument okay the
particularly that Islamic finance
happens is sheltering it from the
current subprime crisis I understand
that but then to make this larger
argument about China and Islamic finance
and then have it be about this
relationship between the states it seems
like that's two very different things
because well you should read the book
it's all there I just video I just
explained to you that this is a
projection so the if you really want to
see how all the different steps that the
best thing would be to read the book
okay we'll make this the last question
people blame any
Russia yes I think Russia will be a very
important counterbalance power I think
what is happening in Russia it is to
assistance and the recreation of the
power of the Soviet Union now one
important thing about Russia is the
resources and I mean first of all they
are strategically positioned but
secondly they have vast vast resources
and putting is moving in a direction
whereby it will reposition Russia where
it was in the past in economic terms but
also I'm afraid in political terms so
we'll see a new word whereby you know
we'll be to a certain stand on the
receiving end of big player big new
players and Russia will be one of this
player if not the biggest one of course
because we'll have you know China but it
will be the importance of Russia in this
game will be bigger than ours yeah on
that note I want to thank you very much
for being here
thank you
[Applause]